اكلت مفاوضه الطاقه الاوروبيه كادر سمسم
وجود ما سمته تباين كبيرا بين دول الاتحاد
بشان الاتفاق على سقفا لسعر الغاز وداعت
خلال اجتماعي للوزراء الطاقه الاوروبيين
في بروكسل الى ابداء المرونه من اجل
التوسل الى اتفاقتي هذا غدا فشل وزراء
خارجيه الاتحاد في الاتفاق بشان حزمه
عقوبات اضافيه على روسيا بسبب حربها على
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كانك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما الاسباب التي قادت الى
التباين الكبير بين الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان الاتفاق على سقفا
لاسعار الغاز كذلك ما دلاله تزامن هذا
التعثر في التوافق الاوروبي على سقفا لسعر
الغاز مع فشل وزراء الخارجيه الاوروبيين
في الاتفاق بشانه حزمه العقوبات الجديده
على موسكو
وما الذي يمكن ان يفضي اليه الجدل
الاوروبي في التعامل مع التداعيات لحرب
اوكرانيا بعد رفض الكرمل المقترحه لينسكي
للسلام
ورهنه بقبولكيف الوقائع الجديده على الارض
[موسيقى]
بانها كبيره اجتمع وزراء الطاقه
الاوروبيون في العاصمه البلجيكيه في
محاوله للاتفاق على سقف لاسعار الغاز
الاجتماع الذي اعقبت فشل اربعه اجتماعات
اخرى منذ الصيف في هذا العام هو ذلك في
اطار محاوله تقليل لاسعار الكهرباء
الاخيره في الاتحاد الاوروبي شهد خلافا
بشانه سقف السعر الغاز وطريقه شرائه اضافه
الى سبل التعاون بين الدول الاتحاد في
مواجهه نقص امداداته واتساع الحاجه اليه
في ظل تداعيات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
والدخول فصل الشتاء
مفوضه الاتحاد الاوروبي لشؤون الطاقه كادر
سمسم طالبت جميع دول الاتحاد
للوصول الى اتفاق بشان سقف لاسعار الغاز
دول الاتحاد
ومخاوفها حيل هذا الامر متباينه جدا وهذا
الامر الذي اتفقت معها فيه وزيره الطاقه
الفرنسيه لنسمه
فيما يخص القرارات المختلفه لحمايه
المستهلكين والمؤسسات الاوروبيه هذا
الاتفاق سيحقق ثلاثه اهداف هي تامين
امدادات الغاز الخاصه بنا وحمايه المؤسسات
الاقتصاديه والافراد في القاره واستقرار
الاسواق الماليه وهي مساله مطروحه للنقاش
حيث نريد استقرار هذه الاسواق
بالضبط كده
[موسيقى]
الاستاذ العلوم السياسيه في اكاديميه
العلوم السياسيه الروسيه ومن باريس معنا
باتريك فورسي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بكما ضيفنا الكراميه
وابدا معك ضيفنا من
اوروبا من امم
من باريس باتريك فوستيه
واسالك عن طبيعه هذه التباينات التي
شهدناها اليوم بشان التوصل الاتفاق لتحديد
سقف الغاز تفضل
العاب
مشكله تقنيه هنا بسيطه سنحاول حلها بخصوص
الترجمه
كيف تنظر روسيا الى هذا التباين الاوروبي
طيب روسيا تنظر ببساطه لهذه المسائل
دولتنا لن تقوم ببيعه الغاز لتلك الدول
التي سوف تنضم لهذا الاتفاق عن تحديد سقف
الاسعار اوروبا بكل الحالات لن تستطيع ان
تؤمن جميع احتياجاتها
في مجال الغاز بالطبع سوف تحاول امريكا
بفرض على اوروبا فرض شراء الغاز
المثال الذي يعتبر اغلى بكثير من الغاز
الروسي ولكن يجب ان نفهم ان الغاز الروسي
لن يختفي من الاسواق سوف يتوجه الى دول
اخرى الدول التي سوف تكون زبائن جديده
وسوف همم تبيع هذه
الغاز الى الدول الاوروبيه باسعار مربحه
لهذه الدول وسوف يربحون الكثير من الاموال
بهذه الطريقه لذلك واقعيه ما نراه في
اوروبا وفي الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا ضغط
بروسيل على
الحكومات الوطنيه للدول الاوروبيه التي
تفهم جيدا ان بروتين
يقوم بتصرفات على اساس الاوامر الامريكيه
دون ان يهتم بالمصالح لدول المحدده وخاصه
الشعوب التي تسكن في هذه الدول لذلك كل ما
نراه هو همم حقيقه همم كل همم او نتيجه كل
العقوبات والسياسات لهذه العقوبات التي
تعتبر همم
حبل اعدام على رقبه الشعوب
الاوروبيه وهذا يعود بالسوء على هذه
الحكومات التي تضعف اقتصاديا وهمم عن طريق
تحديد هذا السقف لاسعار الغاز
الامريكا الامريكيون يصلون اكثر الى
المزيد من الضرار للاتحاد والاقتصاد
الاوروبي
يعني اشد اذا ما فعلا همم حدث ما حذرت منه
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه عندما قالت ان
روسيا قد توقف الغاز تماما ما واقعيه هذا
الطرح في رايك
ماتشات
روسيا في الواقع لديها كل
الامكانيات حتى ترد بطريقه مماثله لكل
سياسات اوروبا نحن فعلا نستطيع ان نقف ضخ
الغاز بشكل مباشر الى اوروبا ولكن اكرر
اننا بكل الحالات
سنستطيع بل لدينا فعلا
من يستطيع ان يشتري الغاز
روسي وسوف يكون لدينا
دول سوف تكون وسيطه في الواقع وسوف تقوم
ببيع الغاز للاوروبيين ولكن باسعار اعلى
واغلى
ولكنهم لن يسموا هذا الغاز غدا روسيا ولكن
في الواقع سوف يكون هذا هذا اصله روسي
ذلك ابراهيم بالنسبه للاوربيين همم هذا
هذا اعدام وخنق للاقتصاد امام قالته رئيسه
المفوضه الاوروبيه ان
المستودعات الغاز
ممتلئه الى 90% وسوف
يستخدم هذا الغاز الاحتياطي ولكن هذا
الغاز سوف ننظر كيف سوف تكون الشتاء في
اوروبا وكيف سوف ينفذ هذا الغاز الاحتياطي
مشكله تقنيه قد تم حلها
همم في وجه ما يجري وفي وجه هذا التحذير
الذي اطلق كيف نفهم طبيعه التباينات التي
شهد الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان وضع همم
سقف لسان الغاز وهل يمكن تجاوزها
افلام اتحاد الاوروبي سقفا على سعر الغاز
بحوالي
بمبلغ معين واعتقد ان الاقتصاد في ما
يتعلق بالغازي هذا الشتاء ليس مشكله
حقيقيه وكبيره لان قد بدا
الاحتياط تقريبا 100 100 100
لكن المشكله ستظهر في عام 2023 اما هذا
الشتاء فقدت احتياطات اللازمه ومن هنا الى
سنه كامله سنرى ما سيحصل ولكن السعر الغاز
هنا اكرر ليس المشكله اليوم ولو ان الغاز
تقريبا مقطوع تماما تقريبا على اوروبا عدد
الدول الغاره
ولكن هذه ليست مشكله في يومنا هذا وقرر
بفضل الاحتياطي الموجود حاليا
وهو ايضا وبفضل المحطه النوويه الفرنسيه
التي تقدم نصف الطاقه وايضا توفي ايضا
طاقه كهربائيه
وبالتالي المليوم هذه المشكله ليست مشكله
انيه حاليا ستصبح مشكله ربما لاحقا اذا
استمرت هذه الحرب واذا لم اقتصاد ولكن
بالتاكيد هذه ليست مشكله اليوم هذه همم
وايضا ولكن لا يمكن ان ننظر اليها دون
النظر الى ما حصل بالامس فمثلا مراسل
الجزيره في بروكسل نقل عن مصادر اولمبيه
ان حزمه العقوبات التاسعه على روسيا والتي
فشل وزراء الخارجيه بالامس في الاتفاق
بشان هائب الامس الاثنين ستشمل
144 شخصا بينهم عسكريون وصحفيون ومالكه
وسائل الاعلام كشفت المصادر بحسب مراسلنا
ان عدد الافراد على قائمه العقوبات يصل
الى 1100 شخص بينهم مسؤولون حكوميون ورجال
اعمال كما تشمل العقوبات الجديده تجميده
ارصده بنوك الروسيه واخرى تستهدف اقارب
للرئيس الشيشاني ومسؤولين حكميين ومحافظ
ومحافظين مقاطعه كذلك
طبعا
اذا على لسان
المتحدث باسم الكريم رفضت روسيا اقتراح
الرئيس الاوكراني لاحلال السلام والطالبت
بان تاخذ في الاعتبار ما سمته موسكو
الحقائق التي استجددت على الارض اريد فقط
ان اعود لضيفنا هنا باتريك
اذا بالامس فشل الاوروبيين في التوصل على
اتفاق على حزمه عقوبات جديده واليوم هناك
تباين في موضوع سقف الغاز انت تقول لا
يؤثر هذه السنه الشتاء تمضي كما يراد له
احتياطي موجود ولكن
كيف يفهم هذا التباين في الموقفين الان
الامس واليوم
متماسكه امام روسيا ولكن هناك بعض الدول
لديهم بعض المواقف المختلفه قليا نقرر
مثلا
الروسي وبالتالي
فانها حصلت على ترخيص
لكي تستطيع السنتين القادمه
ستكون هناك اسماء جديده والشخصيات جديده
قريبه من الكريم لان هو قريبين من النظام
وبالتالي النظام الروسي طبعا ال- ال-
تعرضون لهذه العقوبات الجديده وان ااه
مثلا
حجز الحسابات المصرفيه هو من على الشركات
من القيام بها عن معاملات تجاريه في
اوروبا هذا
في كل مره في الواقع
الامر يخضع لمناقشاتي قد تكون طويله
وفي وكل شخص يرى قليلا همم
الدعم الاعلامي وان العقوبات ينبغي لا
ينبغي لا ينبغي ان تؤثر على الاوروبيين
هذا هو المهم اذا في كل مره
هناك محاوله لي عقوبه على روسيا نجد هذا
فان هذه العقوبات اللي يجب نحرص انها لا
تكون عقوبه على الدول الاوروبيه
التي هي اللي هي في حاجه الى هذه الامور
وبالتالي لابدنا نكون
هناك مثل هذه التاثيرات المضاده لذلك
اختلافات ولكن بشكل عام وبشكل النهائي همم
حزمه العقوبات سوف نصل تقريبا الحزمه
العاشره وستنجح هو طبعا هذا امر ثقيل
وتاثيرات وتتابعات هذه العقوبات ليست على
هذا القصير على البعيد ستظهر بعد اشهر
عديده همم الثلاثه 14 وليس بين ليله
وضحاها يمكن العقوبات ان تطبقه وان ت-
تاثيراتها همم
بغض النظر
كان الاختلاف هو على مبدا فرض عقوبات
اضافيه ام على تفاصيل هذه العقوبات سيد
بابل سيلزنيف في النهايه اكيد ان روسيا لن
تدر في الدموع على التباين الاوروبي وربما
الى شيء ما تستفيد من هذا الوضع الحالي
ولكن يقول ضيفنا ان العبره بمن يضحك اخيرا
ما تعليقك على الطريقه التي تتعامل فيها
وتستقبل فيها موسكو ما يحدث في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
يصمد
اخذ بعين الاعتبار ان الاوروبيين بهذه
الرغبه الشديده يظهرون
توجههم وجهودهم في
اتخاذ حزمات جديده من العقوبات لان
العقوبات
تمزق الاقتصاد والتواصل الاقتصادي والشبكه
الاقتصاديه بين الدولتين
ولذلك
مهمه الامريكين هنا هو قال الاقسام بيننا
و بعدنا عن بعضنا البعض بيننا وبين
شركائنا ويفرضون على اوروبا القواعد
الخاصه بهم وقواعد اللعبه الخاصه بهم ان
الاستثمار والصناعه همم
اصبحت هذا كله ينتقل من اوروبا الى امريكا
واوروبا تضيع الكثير
سبب هذه العقوبات وانا ااه بسبب واحد هنا
اريد ان اقول ان لو قام قال اوروبيون بس
سؤال لانفسهم ماذا نقوم ماذا نفعل اليوم
هل ناكل او هل ندفئ انفسنا او هل ندخر
المياه حتى نضر بوتين والكريملي هذا يبدو
بشكل مضحك واريد ان اسال هناك هل هذه هي
الديمقراطيه التي يجب ان يدافعون عنها
ويحاربون لاجلها اذا كان ثمن هذه
الديمقراطيه الضرر بالمصالح وبالشعوب
الخاصه بهم لذلك
كابتور يفوجيني لساني بيوت
في الواقع
هنا في بلداننا نظام مختلف عن الديمقراطيه
ولا التصويت والحساب المعارضه والتظاهرات
والاحتجاجات هذه هي الديمقراطيهتنا
وبين الدول الاوروبيه والغربيه تسير على
هذه المبادئ اما طبعا الان
الاوروبيون لا يرغبون الجميع
نظامهم الديمقراطي همم
هذا النظام قد يكون هناك احتجاجات ضده
مخاطيه وبالتالي هو ليس نفس النظام
الموجود في السلطه حاليا في روسيا وتاليفه
كل دوله لها رغباتها وانظمتها وان النظام
الديمقراطي اليوم غير معرض للخطر من قبل
السكان او الشعوب الاوروبيه هذا هو معقوله
لا اعرف ماذا اقول اكثر حول هذا الموضوع
هذا الموضوع
الحديث عن تسويه سلميه البعض يعتقد ربما
تراجع الاوروبيين في التوصل الى يعني موقف
موحد بكل قوه ربما يدل على ان هناك امل في
تسويه وتراجع من جانب الرئيس بوسه هل هذا
همم تفكير رغباوي تعتقد من جانبهم
بجد
والله
يظهرون رغباتهم على انها اشياء واقعيه
الممثلين ان الممثل الدبلوماسي الجزء
[موسيقى]
العسكري ويدع اوروبا لهذا وهذا يعود باثار
سلبيه ان امريكا
اثنين كان فرصه لكسب الوقت لتسليح
اوكرانيا
ضد روسيا وروسيا كانت تقوم
كانت مسؤوله بالالتزام بالقوانين وهذا ما
لا نستطيع ان نقوله عن الشركاء الاخرين
الذين كانوا يحاول ان يستغلوا
اننا نلتزم بوعودنا
الا دقيقه وهنا اريد ان اتوجه للسيد
باتريك فستان فيما يتعلق بموضوع احلال
السلام والمقترح الذي قدمه زينسكي هل
الموقف الاوروبي اليوم في عدم همم الاتفاق
سواء على وضع السقف او فرض عقوبات اضافيه
سقف لسعر الغاز هل فعلا يمكن ان يكون له
تداعيات همم على همم الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا واي نوع من التداعيات
ان العقوبه
تمثل جزء من معارضه اوروبا ضد هذه الحرب
روسيا وبعد ذلك عقوبات وهناك عسكريون
وهناك جوانب اقتصاديه وهناك مساعدات قد
قررت اليوم بعد اجتماعين احدهما
مع الكثير مشاكل كثير الدول الاوروبيه
والامين العام للامم المتحده اذا كان في
باريس من اجل تقديم
مساعدات طارئه
لمساعده او استصلاح المعدات لكم
[موسيقى]